the process you use to create this film
and like crazy I believe it was the same
one used on douchebag which is you
create a story but there's a lot of
improvisation on the day of shooting can
you can you describe for me as the code
screenwriter what is the screenplay like
for a film like this that employs that
technique the more floral way of
describing it that a kind of figure it
is descriptive is it's like if a normal
script is driving directions by street
name our scripts are more like by
landmark so they're a little bit less
specific in terms of what the actors
actually say in fact most of the
dialogue is improvised the script runs
almost the same length as a normal
screenplay because we put a lot of
backstory onto the page and John what's
it like to to shoot improvisation you
know Drake knows exactly what to expect
and we all do so is it mapped out a
little bit before he calls action do the
actors ever say okay you know I'm gonna
do this or I'm gonna do that or yeah
that's a little bit a lot of times he
just has them show up in the space
without having seen it before so we have
to we have to plan accordingly to that
but Drake and I sit down ahead of time
and and we do we plan everything out
like we sit down and we shot list the
entire thing so it is really specific as
far as that goes but then there's a lot
of things where you know you you plan a
little bit where you say like well we
don't know what they're gonna do in the
room so we don't know where we're gonna
need coverage or we don't know you know
and maybe it's just going to work in one
shot so we plan accordingly to that
where a lot of times we'll will you know
shoot through a doorway or through a
window or something like that to begin
with so that we can get the entire scene
in one one full take and and also since
it's improv he doesn't he doesn't cut
very often - so a lot of times he'll say
let's just go to the end of the corridor
until we're you know until we run out of
data since it's digital how long do you
usually have cuz you know in the old
days when you were shooting film
you know what would you get like maybe
10-15 minutes out of the room yeah we
get about 14 minutes still yeah you can
have larger cards to get twice not but
we usually do 14 minutes and he usually
says let's just let's just go all the
way and when it's over let's just keep
going and a lot of times that's where
you get those moments where they're just
sort of staring at each other like that
moment by the swingset where it's really
dark like the the reason it's so dark in
that scene which we loved at the end is
because that was 15 minutes into attack
and the Sun had gone down so that and
and and I think that ends up being
something you know even more special
than what we intended it to be because
it's a happy accident then is that the
reason for employing this technique is
that yeah I guess yeah you opened
yourself up more to you know problems or
missed shots but that you also open
yourself up to little miracles like that
I think that's exactly the reason for it
um it's not necessarily an advisable way
to make a movie because you do end up
with you know a lot of but if you're
rolling for 15 minutes on one take that
ends up being a few moments in the film
you know you end up with a lot of
footage you aren't going to use and it
creates kind of a little bit of a
traffic jam in the editing room but yeah
the result or rather the the benefit is
you do stumble upon those happy
accidents and those moments between the
moments and in the case of both like
crazy and breathe in from the very
beginning that's a lot of what we were
going for was trying to make films that
were about what wasn't said one thing is
we do account for the fact that there
will likely need to be additional
footage shot after principal photography
because if you're dealing with
improvisation there's a chance that some
story element doesn't get captured
properly something falls through the
cracks you know sometimes just
connective tissue is needed for the
scenes or that the tone is slightly off
and you need could be you know to
reshoot sure it could be and so there's
a there's a contingency in terms of time
and budget and everyone knows we may
have to go back and that's planned for
there are moments that that Drake sees
something happening and he says oh let's
let's shoot this let's do like the scene
where they're playing Jenga that was
just a like an acting exercise that they
had done in prep which was that you know
they would just sit and play Jenga as a
family and and and and and just be in
character for the whole game and they
were doing that on set and and and you
know we decided we'd shoot at once so
they played Jenga for 20 minutes and we
shot the whole thing and then that
little bit of it ends up in the movie
but then this time as well like what was
interesting is that when we did go back
to do the reshoots they they fully
scripted them all to so and so I think
there's what a handful of scenes in
there that were reshot that we did over
4 days almost a year later that were
just completely scripted some of the
more some of the more pivotal scenes
were more important since the titular
scene the breathing exercise for example
is traditionally scripted so that you
know we know that we're hitting the mark
I mean the you know we were there during
the hurricane that year to which which
we got shut down for so there was a lot
leading up think there was an earthquake
that year too when we know that's like
wow yeah and no but we would we would
just go with it and then when you
manufacture it it's it's like my worst
nightmare because you have to yeah it's
you have to be shooting at the right
time and like the the scene sort of
after the storm when their guy and
Felicity are getting to know each other
more with the beers is what I mean it
was like bright Sun outside the whole
time during that and we just we had a
plan that that you know we knew that
that was probably what was going to
happen and we are on such a abbreviated
schedule and we shot that over the
course of two days so we just we had a
plan to manufacture most of the movie is
really really natural feeling and and
available a lot of its available like
when we're inside so that was difficult
just because we needed to fit into the
same movie there's a million ways that
you can decide to make it look gloomy
inside and all that so it was that was
probably the biggest challenge to me on
that movie was trying to make it fit in
with the rest the story of a an older
man a family man falling for a younger
girl that's been explored and that just
that simple premise has been explore
a lot of different ways what was it that
made you see a new angle or something
fresh - basically we discovered and
started to go with the idea that this is
a you know a story we're kind of
familiar with but the difference is it's
not gonna be about carnal desires it's
not going to be about an older man
lusting after a younger woman it's gonna
be about two kindred spirits who are
different ages unfortunately